okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over ribonucleic acid RNA and the
process in which RNA is created which is
called transcription so let's go ahead
and get started
so ribonucleic acid first of all RNA
ribonucleic acid here's a picture to
kind of help you compare and contrast
some of the very basics of DNA versus
RNA you may know DNA is a double helix
well if you look at the picture RNA
ribonucleic acid is a single nucleotide
a single strand of of nucleotides
chained together well it's a nucleic
acid RNA is a nucleic acid and all
nucleic acids are made from smaller
subunits called nucleotides and in the
picture you can you can see that a
nucleotide has three basic building
blocks to them a phosphate molecule of
sugar molecule and then one of the
various kinds of nitrogenous bases and
so the sugar DNA has a sugar by the name
of deoxyribose RNA the name of the sugar
is called ribose and notice RNA has four
nitrogen bases adenine guanine cytosine
and uracil so here is a different
nitrogen base we're used to seeing T
four thiamine if we studied DNA earlier
well thiamine exists in DNA molecules
however uracil exists in RNA molecules
so just notice that the uracil is kind
of replacing thymine in the world of RNA
ultimately we're going to discuss
briefly the three basic types of RNA so
let's go ahead and get started with
what's called messenger RNA so here's a
very simple diagram of kind of the cell
and the nucleus on the left inside of
the nucleus we have a double helix piece
of DNA outside the nucleus is the
cytoplasm and here's a ribosome drift
around in the cytoplasm so mrna is what
we're gonna call messenger RNA from now
on the M stands for messenger well you
know what a messenger does a messenger
is going to make a copy of some kind of
information and deliver it to another
another individual and so in this case
the reason it's called messenger RNA is
DNA holds the information needed to
build a protein but the DNA is stuck in
the nucleus the ribosome is the actual
builder of a protein so there has to be
a way to get the DNA information from
inside the nucleus to the ribosome there
has to be a go-between and that's what
mRNA is what mRNA does is it kind of
makes a temporary copy of DNA you notice
in the animation a temporary copy a
piece of RNA is exiting the nucleus and
going towards the ribosome the once that
happens the RNA will arrive at the
ribosome and you might already know from
studying biology earlier in our school
year that ribosomes jobs are to build
proteins
well ribosomes build proteins but they
need a copy of the information from DNA
in order to build that protein that's
the job of messenger RNA deliver genetic
information to the ribosome that way the
ribosome can properly build a protein so
messenger RNA starts in the nucleus
because that's where DNA is found
messenger RNA is actually created in the
nucleus but the messenger RNA will then
exit the nucleus through one of the
nuclear pores and attach and attach
itself to a ribosome and we're going to
learn more about this another day so
another kind of RNA I want to mention is
what is called transfer RNA you'll often
hear it simply called T tRNA and then
again my picture here I have a ribosome
drifting around in the side
plasm and those three colored circles
are three different kinds of what are
called amino acids amino acids kind of
have some strange names to them you can
see one in pink cut leucine one an
orange called prolene one in yellow
called serine there's another amino acid
by the name of Matheny and there's
another amino acid by the name of
asparagine so they kind of have some
weird names to them well the function of
transfer RNA the function of T RNA tRNA
its job is to pick up an amino acids
such as serine and deliver it to a
ribosome you might know that the job of
a ribosome is to build a protein
proteins are made from amino acids and
so again what happens is a tRNA here in
this case picks up the amino the amino
acid called leucine and the tRNA will
transfer the leucine to the ribosome and
in this case the leucine can be bonded
with the other amino acid called serine
and the process simply repeats itself
here's another tRNA that picks up the
orange amino acid called prolene
it's called transfer RNA because
transfer RNA will transfer the amino
acid prolene over to the ribosome and
now prolene will be added to the growing
chain of amino acids that's what a
protein is a protein is a chain of amino
acids and so really what the ribosome
does is once transfer RNA delivers the
amino acid the ribosome kind of links
all the amino acids into a big long
chain and we eventually call that a
polypeptide and and then polypeptides
can make proteins and so the functional
location of where we find tRNA is in the
cytoplasm now all kinds of RNA are made
in the nucleus but the functional
location of tRNA is really in the
cytoplasm so next I want to mention a
type of RNA called our RNA and our
stands for ribosomal the reason that
stands for ribosomal is because in the
picture here you
the ribosomes if you recall ribosomes
are the most numerous the most plentiful
organelle within the cell
well ribosomes are actually made from
long or I should say from big complex
strips of our RNA and so that's the
reason why we're mentioning our RNA and
the reasons the R stands for ribosomal
is because our RNA are the components of
what ribosomes it's our RNA is what
ribosomes are made from now eventually
we're going to learn today in this video
a process called transcription and if
you're in my biology class in a couple
of days we're gonna learn another
process called translation and when we
learn transcription and translation
we're more gonna focus our attention on
messenger RNA and tRNA but I did want to
mention our RNA because ribosomes
actually play a big role in these
processes as well so the process that I
want to focus on for the rest of this
video is a process called transcription
and in this process RNA in this process
of transcription RNA is going to be
created from a molecule of DNA so here's
a cell let's zoom in into the nucleus
and so here's a nucleus well let's zoom
out into the nucleus for a closer look
when we zoom out into the nucleus again
we have twisted spiraled double helix
molecules of DNA well let's kind of get
a closer look at and a single strand of
DNA here and so again a single strand of
DNA here we see a double helix and
notice chargaff's rules adenine pairs
with everything I mean and cytosine
pairs with every guanine well during the
process called transcription enzyme by
the name of RNA polymerase is gonna
break the hydrogen bonds between the A's
and the T's between the Seas and the G's
in my animation RNA polymerase is going
to be symbolized by these scissors
scissors of course are used to cut and
in this case RNA polymerase cuts apart
the the strands of DNA so now that the
double helix has been separated let's
move on to step two step two remind
ourselves that the nucleus it's not
filled with empty hollow air space the
nucleus is filled with the fluid much
like the cytoplasm fills up the inside
of a cell and floating around in the
fluid of the nucleus are various solutes
and in this case we want to focus on on
nucleotides there are nucleotides that
are floating around unpaired
free-floating nucleotides that are in
the nucleus and what happens what we're
gonna do is we're gonna perform
transcription in this animation look at
the top the top strand of ATT CC g80
and so on look at the top strip of black
DNA letters from left to right let's
perform transcription if there's a DNA a
an RNA you is gonna match up if there's
a DNA in black RNA a the next one would
be an A the next one will be a G the
next one will be a G the next one will
be a C the next one will be a you
remember there's no T's because we're
building RNA if you're wondering why
some of the letters are capitalized and
some of the letters are lowercase I'll
explain later
let's continue performing transcription
notice how there's a black DNA T well in
floats a red RNA a and so on from left
to right down the entire chain of DNA
that's been separated and eventually we
get to the end and this piece of mRNA is
near completion it's not complete it's
not final yet watch what happens next
so step 3 that big strip of red RNA is
gonna break free and as it breaks free
what happens next is a processed I'm
going to simply call RNA processing
let's look at that step 4
step four RNA processing occurs what
happens is now I have to explain why
there's uppercase letters and lower
cased in Mikey that just appeared
I want to designate the uppercase
letters to be things called exons and I
want to designate the lowercase letters
to be things called introns what introns
and exons are they are portions of RNA
introns are portions of unused RNA exons
are portions of used RNA and we don't
really quite understand why this is but
there are portions of the RNA that are
not used
we call those introns in my animation
there the lowercase letters watch what
happens to the introns the introns are
removed the introns are removed again we
don't really quite understand much of
why this occurs but this is the pattern
that we see now watch what happens with
the remaining exons the remaining exons
barn together and this is the final
piece of RNA that was created from the
black strip of DNA so that was RNA
processing where the introns have been
removed and the exons were kind of
spliced and bonded together and so step
5
this final strip of RNA will exit and go
towards a ribosome well that's actually
if we kind of focus this animation on
messenger RNA let's pretend that that
red strip of letters was messenger RNA
messenger RNA travels to a ribosome and
will go and follow that messenger RNA in
a few moments but let's let's kind of
finish up what happens in the nucleus
first step six the DNA double helix
recombines eventually this process can
repeat itself eventually those animated
scissors representing RNA polymerase can
re separate the DNA
make more RNA and the process can repeat
itself well you know let's go find that
strip of red RNA that just exited it
went over to the right so let's go find
it well I'm looking over to the right I
don't quite see it again we're zooming
around the nucleus trying to find it
let's let's keep looking here it is so
here is the red strip of RNA again we're
gonna call this messenger RNA again
there are three types of RNA but let's
just talk messenger RNA for now this
messenger RNA is going to exit the
nucleus and enter into the cytoplasm
remember the nucleus has a little pores
in it called the nuclear pores and so
there goes the messenger RNA has just
exited the nucleus and into the
cytoplasm oh let's go find it let's go
follow that red strip of messenger RNA
so here's a ribosome a cell part known
as a ribosome messenger RNA will come on
in and attach itself to the ribosome
what happens next is a process that
we're gonna learn more about another day
but the process is called translation
you already know from earlier chapter in
the school year that a ribosomes job is
to build a protein and it will
accomplish that goal by performing a
process called translation in the
process of translation the ribosome will
build a protein that's something we're
gonna learn more about another day in
another video but I can always introduce
it briefly right here for those of you
that would like of just a real quick
side-by-side comparison of DNA versus
RNA here you go you know look at the
bottom on the left when it says the
location of DNA is in the nucleus well
this is clearly referring to eukaryotic
cells eukaryotic cells have a nucleus if
you recall bacteria are prokaryotes and
they lack a nucleus but this this
diagram right here just shows some very
simple differences between DNA and RNA
eukaryotes and so there you go if you're
in my biology class you know pause the
video pause the video and try to answer
these questions on perhaps a separate
sheet of paper I'd be happy to check
your answers before school or after
school one day so go ahead and pause the
video try to answer the questions good
luck